on a sunny tuesday afternoon on the
northeastern outskirts of paris 100
passengers began the boarding process
onto the world's fastest commercial
plane
navigating down the narrow body of the
concorde with pairs of business class
seats flanking them on each side
[Music]
flight 4590 was a charitable flight
carrying the predominantly german
passengers to embark on an adventurous
journey through the caribbean the panama
canal and finally ecuador aboard the ms
deutschland
the crew of the flight was composed of
the captain a 53 year old pilot with
over 300 hours flown in the concorde the
first officer was a 50 year old with
over 2 000 hours of concord flight time
and the flight engineer who again
accumulated over 900 hours of flying
with the concorde
at 2 34 pm ground control gave clearance
for the flight to take off from runway
26r the longest runway at charles de
gaulle airport which was needed to get
the concorde's cumbersome delta wings up
to take off speed
at 2 40 pm flight air france 4590 lined
up at the start of runway 26r beginning
the exciting takeoff sequence the
world's only commercial plane to employ
after burners
20 seconds later the first officer calls
out that they've reached 100 knots
six seconds later the officer calls out
v1 the point of no return aborting the
take-off now was no longer an option as
there was not enough runway left to stop
in time
a mere two seconds later a loud crash is
heard from the left wing and flames are
seen billowing from the plane crashing
just moments later into a nearby hotel
what followed was a multi-year air crash
investigation unraveling the cause of
the accident from the wreckage using
engineering
this is its story
[Music]
the challenge facing air crash
investigators for any tragic loss like
this is immense the concorde had crashed
into a small hotel and restaurant almost
10 kilometers southwest of charles de
gaulle airport
flames had consumed the area around the
crash site leaving the investigators a
scattered and scorched debris field to
piece back together
the investigators started by organizing
the accident site to discover clues
about what had happened
clipped trees north of the hotel crash
site suggested that the plane had
crashed while heading south
following along that southward
trajectory the runes of the concorde's
powerful turbojet engines were scattered
on the darkened burnt ground
the site was littered with large impact
marks with pieces of fuselage embedded
in the ground
further south the main cabin was found
alongside the tragic victims of the
crash to the east like the cockpit and
its burned instruments
not all of the instruments survived the
flames and many of them were missing
however a few instruments did survive
the crash and the heat
the investigators noted down the final
readings and the dials they could read
this would hopefully provide crucial
information that would lead to a
revelation as the investigation
continued
as they dug through the remains of the
aircraft they found the flight data
recorder the tool that stores critical
data about the plane's flight record
they also found the cockpit voice
recorder allowing the investigators to
listen to the plane's final moments
in these audio recordings a large bang
is heard shortly after the officer
called out v1 at the same moment the
flight data recorder displayed a sudden
loss of speed and thrust in engine
number two on the left wing followed
closely by its neighbor engine 1.
while engines 1 and 2 were struggling
the data showed that the plane kept
flying with an almost constant angle of
attack without gaining altitude while
the loss of thrust on the left wing
caused the plane to roll
this flight data and the audio
recordings provided a lot of evidence as
to what had happened but it left a
crucial question unanswered what was
that loud noise that preceded the fire
and what caused it
to find more clues the investigators
turned their attention to the runway
even without the data recordings the
scorched concrete painted a vivid
picture of the concord's final moments
it was clear from the burned grass and
damaged lights that the concord had lost
control and veered to the left while
irregular marks in the concrete and
chunks of rubber pointed to a left tire
failure
along the chair trail the plane left
more breadcrumb clues crucial to
continuing the investigation
besides the damaged rubber tire two
other items stood out to the
investigation a mysterious titanium
strip with irregular drilled holes and
an unscorched piece of the plane no
larger than a sheet of printer paper
they were perplexed by the thin metal
strip irregular drilled holes are not
very common in the industry
this led to investigators trying to
match the 42 centimeter long strip to
any component of the concorde but they
couldn't find a match for it anywhere in
the design documents
they concluded that this strip was not
part of the plane and had been there
before the plane took off
logically the next step was to
scrutinize all of the departing flights
on the same runway to identify where
this metal strip could have come from
flight 4590 left at 2 30 pm they scoured
through all of the maintenance and
engineering documents for any plane that
took off after 1pm
one of the many papers they went through
pointed them in the right direction a
mcdonnell douglas dc10 that was
servicing a continental flight that left
a mere five minutes before the air
france flight had a maintenance document
referencing a metallic wear strip
the maintenance documents showed that
the plane had undergone repairs of a
metal wear strip just one month prior in
tel aviv
the same document showed that the
maintenance was not up to manufacturing
standards to confirm the investigators
tracked down the dc-10 and found it was
missing a wear strip with the same
irregular drilled holes the culprit's
fingerprints had been matched to the
scene of the crime
the investigators concluded that a few
minutes before flight 4590 was due to
depart the continental flight dropped
its wear strip on the runway crucially a
32 centimeter long cut was found in the
rubber tire debris left on the runway
while it was tempting to connect this 42
centimeter long metal strip and the cut
found in the tire the investigators
could not assume it was the cause
to confirm investigators built a
simulated concorde a wagon modified to
fit a new concord tire loaded with 25
tons to simulate the weight of the
aircraft and indeed the strip cut the
tyre exactly as seen in the crashed
debris
however this only answers why a tire
would burst
crucially this does not answer how a
tyre burst would cause the eventual
fiery crash
after all this crash was not the first
time the concorde suffered a burst tyre
during takeoff
during its 30-year program the concorde
experienced 57 tire malfunctions 22 of
these events happened during takeoff and
19 were caused by a foreign object in 12
of these events structural damage was
seen and six experienced fuel tank
penetrations but none caused a fire like
the one seen on flight 4590
one event in particular stands out on
the 14th of june 1979 an air france
concord took off from jules airport in
washington dc heading to paris
during the takeoff one of the tires
burst and caused punctures in three of
the tanks
this led to fuel being leaked at a rate
of 4 kilograms per second
luckily the crew noticed the damage and
24 minutes after takeoff they landed
safely back at jules airport
in the report that followed this
incident it was stated that the risk of
fire was low after penetration of the
tanks they stated that the low rate of
fuel leakage coupled with scarce
ignition sources did not pose a
significant risk of fire
they also stated that even in the event
of a leak the location of the tanks
would cause the fuel to disperse rather
than accumulate
the images and videos of the concorde in
flames play in stark contrast to the
findings from this previous
investigation this of course begs the
question what was different about this
flight that led to this infamous picture
to answer that question the
investigators needed to quantify the
fuel leak rate of flight 4590
visual evidence that came from videos
and images of the crash provided the
first clues
using these images the investigators
could estimate the dimensions of the
flames trailing behind the concord's
wing gauging the flame to be 50 meters
long 3 meters in diameter and 10
centimeters thick
they could estimate the rate of fuel
leak needed to sustain such a blaze at
60 kilograms per second
one of the instruments that survived the
crash confirmed this number with the
initial fuel load known some simple
calculations confirmed the fuel leak at
a rate of 60 kilograms per second using
the fuel dial still stuck in its final
position 15 times greater than the 4
kilogram per second leak witnessed in
the previous incident at jules airport
this points to a very different fuel
leak mechanism
here is where the third piece of
evidence from the runway helped the
investigators solve the mystery of the
crash
a single 30 centimeter by 30 centimeter
piece of tank was found on the runway
this piece held the secrets to what
happened to an untrained eye this piece
of metal wouldn't stand out
coated in the concord's white heat
resistant paint on one side and
strengthening struts running along its
length on the other this was enough
detail to pinpoint exactly where in the
plane it came from tank number five
right above the landing gear
next the investigators noted that the
piece was not burned at all indicating
that it dropped before the fire started
to crack the final piece of the puzzle
the investigators needed a material
science expert
to an untrained eye the fracture surface
of a metal tells you little but to an
expert in fracture mechanics it tells
the story
the investigator's report noted that the
ruptures and the thin skin were matte
for the most part the rupture face was
angled at 45 degrees which indicates
that these were static ruptures
to understand the significance of this
passage we need some background on
fracture mechanics
why does a 45 degree rupture face
indicate a static rupture
let's run a couple of examples with
different materials undergoing different
types of stress and see how their
fracture geometries vary the
investigators knew that the type of
aluminium being used in the tank was a
ductile material
if we take a ductile material and apply
stress to it as its name implies the
material sample would deform as the load
increases this leads to a phenomenon
called necking where the material thins
out until it can't stand a larger load
and then fails
this leaves a characteristic 45 degree
angle on the failed piece
often in these types of failures you can
see a cup and ball surface again at a 45
degree angle
these types of surfaces only happen to
ductile materials under tension if
another type of stress would be applied
to the sample say torsional stress then
the material would break with a 90
degree angle
examining the fracture surface of this
piece told the experts working on this
case a story
the hole in the tank wasn't caused by a
puncture by the tire physically piercing
the tank it pointed towards a rupture
caused by a buildup of pressure inside
the tank
the piece of rubber hit the underside of
the wing with enough force to cause a
deformation in the tank
causing the walls of the tank to bend in
while adjacent sections bulged out
this was a serious problem because the
fuel was incompressible and being the
start of the flight the tanks were full
the resulting pressure wave slammed down
into the bulging sections and ejected
the piece of tank found on the runway
and a hole this large was capable of
causing a fuel leak large enough to
match the flames seen in the images of
the tragic accident
the scene was set a poorly positioned
metal strip caused a stressed tire to
burst and slam against the underside of
the wing which in turn led to a massive
pressure wave inside the tank which
ruptured the tank leading to a
catastrophic and tragic loss of power
leading to the plane's uncontrollable
descent
a decade-long legal battle ensued
between air france and continental where
they took turns pointing fingers at each
other finalizing in a 2010 court ruling
that fined continental 1 million euros
plans were made to add kevlar liners to
the fuel tanks to prevent further static
ruptures like this and potential
electric ignition sources were also
moved and reinforced in the area new
damage resilient tires were also
introduced
however these modifications meant little
for the financially struggling concorde
this crash proved to be the final nail
in the coffin for the airline with high
ticket prices and low demand for flights
becoming even lower in the wake of the
crash the concorde proved to be
financially unviable leading to both
british airways and air france to cancel
their supersonic flying programs the end
of an era marked by a tragic crash
i hesitated making this video for
youtube as it deals with the tragic
accident and it's not always clear what
will and won't upset the youtube
demonetization system that's why i moved
all my world war ii related content to
nebula where i can continue making
videos about a subject i am passionate
about without having to worry about
youtube views between my logistics of
d-day in battle of britain's series i
have over three hours of documentaries
you can watch right now
this isn't like the same old boring
history documentaries being remade over
and over again these days repeating
themselves constantly for their 30
minute run times so they can fit enough
ads in this is in-depth research
distilled into three hours of
entertaining and informative
documentaries the same nitty-gritty
detail you've come to enjoy from real
engineering just applied to a different
genre
we will also be sharing additional
content from our upcoming documentary
about spin launch in the coming month as
we have hours of footage that will end
up on the cutting room floor without a
suitable place to share it
we are just one of the creators using
nebula to experiment and make videos
that may not work on youtube there is
real life laura's modern conflict series
wendover productions game show that i
competed in where you will see some of
my usual day-to-day chaotic personality
that i desperately try to hide from you
on this channel
nebula is not just the home of extra
videos it's a proving ground for new
ideas and concepts that helps us as
content creators to experiment and
develop our skills
skills that have bled into these videos
with our 3d animation abilities growing
thanks to the battle of britain series
on top of all that the best and cheapest
way to get access to nebula is by
signing up to curiositystream for the
low price of 14.79 a year that will get
you access to curiosity streams massive
library of award-winning documentaries
and get nebula bundled in for free you
can sign up with the link on screen
right now
or if you're looking for something else
right now you can watch our last video
about spacex's new rocket fuel or watch
real sciences latest video explaining
why crows are so smart
[Music]
you